>>> WELL, I HAVE THE FIRST GOOD
NEWS IN WEEKS.
THE INFECTION STOPPED SPREADING,
YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE A FULL
RECOVERY.
WE ALMOST LOST YOU CHAD.
>> OKAY.
>> I HAVE TO SAY, I AM GOING TO
MISS YOU, CHAD.
>> OKAY.
>> AND I'VE --JUST SAY IT THEN,
I THINK I HAVE FALLEN IN LOVE
WITH YOU, CHAD.
>> OKAY.
>> YOU MUST HAVE A MILLION
THOUGHTS RACING THROUGH YOUR
MIND.
YOU ARE DRIVING ME CRAZY.
EVERY TIME I LOOK AT YOU, I JUST
WANT TO CLIMB IN THAT BED AND
MAKE SWEET LOVE TO YOU.
>> NICE.
>> BUT WE CAN'T.
>> OH, OKAY.
>> I'M YOUR DOCTOR FOR GOD
SAKES.
>> OKAY.
BUT I MUST CONFESS, I HAVE
FANTASIZED ABOUT LAYING ON YOUR
CHEST WHILE YOU PLAY WITH MY
HAIR, TALKING ABOUT OUR LIVES,
OUR HOPES, OUR DREAMS --
>> I PEED.
>> I UNDERSTAND IF YOU THINK
THAT MY ARGUMENT LACKS VALIDITY.
>> HA HA.
TITTY.
>> IT COULD NEVER HAPPEN.
I WOULD BE FIRED FOR BECOMING
INVOLVED WITH A PATIENT.
IS IT CRAZY I WOULD BE WILLING
TO RISK MY ENTIRE CAREER TO BE
WITH YOU, CHAD?
CHAD?
CHAD, COULD YOU PLEASE COME BACK
HERE FOR A MOMENT?
>> OH, OKAY.
>> I'M A DOCTOR.
I LISTEN TO HEARTS EVERY DAY.
IT'S TIME I LISTEN TO MY OWN.
IT WANTS YOU, CHAD.
OH GOD, IT'S RACING RIGHT NOW.
>> YO IS THAT A ZIT OR A HERPE?
>> I THINK IT IS A LITTLE
INGROWN HAIR.
>> DOPE.
>> NOW GET SOME SLEEP, YOUNG
MAN.
AND DREAM ABOUT ME.
DOCTOR'S ORDERS.
>> OKAY.
>> AND CHAD --
[ KNOCKING ]
YOU KNOW, I NEVER ASKED HOW HE
GOT SICK?
>> OH, HIS FRIEND DARED HIM TO
EAT A DOG TURD.
♪♪♪
>> GOD, THAT'S SEXY.
>> OKAY.